I'm taking the Carlisle brand Black Kohash,
750 milligram tablets about three per day,
and I'm still having hot flashes during the day
and also that wake me up at night.
Would you suggest a different brand or a higher dose
of what I'm taking?
They worked for me three years ago, but not now.
Okay, so somebody who is ER and or PR
or HER2 positive negative,
or HER2 positive cancer,
you know, you're trying to get your estrogen levels down.
So you want your estrogen levels to be down
because you don't want your estrogen levels
to be blocking the estrogen beta receptor.
So that's the whole idea.
So it's a kind of a catch 22.
If my estrogen levels then go down,
that could be better to help my body kill the cancer.
However, my estrogen levels go down,
that could be bad because I'm gonna end up with hot flashes.
So it's this balancing act with somebody with cancer.
Now, if you're cancers in a relative state of remission again,
then you could use some natural things
to help balance estrogen so that you don't have
the side effects of low estrogen, aka hot flashes and such.
If that's the case,
hey, my cancer's in relative state of remission
and I'm using like cohosh to try to balance my hormones,
but it's not working now.
Well, a couple things could be going on.
Remember, some of the brands of supplements
that contain herb, herbs,
sometimes the batch is just a bad batch.
And if we sent it into a organic chemistry lab
and tested it, it might not actually have 750 milligram
black cohosh in it, it might only have seven milligrams
seriously a black cohosh.
That's why it's not working.
These companies are getting their products
in almost most of these herbs are coming from China.
And if they're not checking each batch to be
very specific with what is rigid on the label,
which a lot of these companies,
like I think the Carlisle brand,
which is kind of an off cheaper brand,
it could be all over the board as far as what's actually
in the capsules.
So, A, you could switch to a different brand,
you could have a bunch of that try taking a higher dose,
but again, it would be based upon where you're at
with your cancer because you don't want to,
you know, do something that could relatively raise your,
spike your estrogen and then cause blockage
of the receptor site, which could possibly increase
the growth of your cancer.
So, a lot of reasons why is it not working for somebody,
one of them would certainly be the quality
of the product itself.